well this is a hard one because the last
one seems very fake but you've been
being kind of a tricky tricky bastard
first of all they're all reasonable I'm
gonna go manic your station might be the
chicken though is I like like what just
randomly gonna be good in every city
doubtful it seems like the obvious fake
let me get going weather usually jigging
you soon see huh I'll sleep me
you tricked me on purpose
well you just took the default of the
one that nobody change it's not about
you
be be I think fine with a new Tabasco
bottle
we weren't I went knocking by yes with
your NATO's and I would not be found
with a night individually-wrapped
I'm gonna boxers barber's chair
I'm gonna go masseuse [ __ ] yeah that's
what I pick well I was right so you were
correct
did you really pick it yes good did you
pick boxers no I picked masseuse I could
just run the tape back my Oh boxers my
watch
we already know that's really as we work
it we've worked our there so I'm gonna
say via to VM what you did I'm sure the
temperature was listen she didn't really
Wow
she wanted to buy we had to our bags
over all right we did not actually do
anything weird is it after works
obviously
I'm gonna go the socks because socks
come in one size managerís is just odd
because he said like bit yeah I kind of
want it now that I know we're talking
about keeper grunts ox we have white
socks
well I'm Way behind so I'm gonna say hey
I don't remember what it was back extra
small saw Judaism to keep his narge warm
oh look at me like a Chili Peppers thing
yeah but just the nards yeah no one's
nards are as big as a foot or can't
believe you just admitted on tape figure
nards or not that's not your nards are
as big as a foot yes that's disgusting
what's our writer do we we don't have
what I don't know yeah we do like mango
and we have ones I thought it's just
like stuff we like but not demands